cuéntenos que está contribuyendo a que
los incendios sean tan frecuentes
especialmente en esta región de
argentina
hola muy buenas tardes muchísimas
gracias por la invitación bueno la
verdad que los esfuerzos son arduos para
combatir los focos de incendio que hoy
siguen azotando nuestra vegetación
nativa sobre todo vegetación sumamente
importante hoy tenemos casi el 70% de
nuestros humedales consumidos el 40% de
nuestros pastizales afectados y un
sinfín de especies silvestres que se
desplazan en todo el territorio
argentino en busca de refugio en busca
de amor porque recordemos que nuestros
humedales se encuentran completamente
secos porque venimos de un periodo de
dos años consecutivos de una sequía en
cuanto de vegetación y en cuanto a
hídrica entonces la situación cada vez
empeora y las precipitaciones en cuanto
a lluvia no son nada favorables y mucho
menos los panoramas de aquí en adelante
cuáles han sido las respuestas de las
autoridades para para atender este tipo
de emergencias
bueno la verdad es que hoy se está
trabajando de manera ardua pero los
esfuerzos por parte de los organismos
provinciales así como nacionales la
verdad que no daban abasto porque los
fuegos ya están muy avanzados los focos
de incendios están muy avanzados y sobre
todo son focos de ignición sumamente
grandes son de gran magnitud que hoy no
hablamos de minutos sino hablamos de ese
mundo en cuanto a consumición de la
vegetación entonces hoy la actuación del
gobierno está trabajando de manera
conjunta con el gobierno nacional pero
los esfuerzos para poder combatir los
focos de incendio creo y las medidas que
se tomaron fueron un poco tarde